it is May of 2018 and I've just spent
the better part of a month immersed in
zombie fiction
I've poured hours into state of decay
too I fought my fair share of battles
and they are billions
I've also stayed in touch with a friend
by playing through Resident Evil Code
Veronica that's not to mention my recent
return to classic movies such as 28 days
later or Shaun of the Dead
what's more sony has been revealing more
footage of its upcoming days gone and
we're also set to see zombies mode
return with black ops 4 and if you
consider fungus infected humans to be
zombies then the Last of Us part 2 will
round out an undead heaviiy 3 all of
this begs the question why do zombies
still fascinate us this decade has been
saturated with the reanimated monsters
from The Walking Dead's mainstream
success to war war Z's 540 million
dollar box office showing common refrain
would suggest that by now we should be
tired of the undead horde YouTube
comments very likely on this video
itself will probably say something to
that effect but games such as black ops
4 state of decay two days gone and dying
light suggests otherwise
they hint that not only as the genre
going to survive but it could very well
continue to flourish and I think that's
a better trend than most of us give it
credit for
Zombies fit well into video games there
are enemies at their most basic with
relatively simple AI lacking both
purpose and motivation they don't take
cover
they don't use complex tactics and when
triggered they run straight at you
becoming cannon fodder for your firearm
crowbar or Molotov cocktails put simply
video game zombies provide catharsis
they're simple and in many ways the
ideal video game opponent of course
they're also a strong source of dread
zombies spawn in the everyday world
whether it's the idyllic suburb or the
overgrown urban sprawl they transform
places we once found familiar lending
potential danger to every barn gas
station or alleyway is their constant
threat that makes supply runs terrifying
in state of decay it's their relentless
hunger that instills fear in dying
lights open world say what you will
about the genre and the zombie fatigue
many of us have felt in the past few
years but these games rarely contain a
dull moment
I think these pillars these assumptions
about zombie games that makes them so
much money players have a general sense
of what they're getting into when they
buy one there will probably be aspects
of survival decision-making and stealth
there will also be an element of horror
but not too much horror this general
consistency in the design of zombie
games is in my mind crucial developers
can use the undead and they're almost
guaranteed profit as Trojan horses for
gameplay innovations take left for dead
for instance on the surface it was a
co-op focus zombie shooter but valve
took the opportunity to introduce the
director an AI that remapped weapons
items and enemies every time you played
state of decay on the other hand use
zombies to create a survival focused
immersive sim with hardcore permadeath
design and they are billions
reinvigorated the RTS genre in general
using zombies to demonstrate an
overwhelming sense of numbers by using
our undead pop culture icons developers
can disguise risks as commercial
guarantees it's a testament to the
flexibility of zombie games that they've
slowly spread into so many genres over
the years one might focus on melee
combat while the next emphasizes puzzles
and exploration some make use of open
worlds while others guides you along
pritu
and paths zombies are less of an enemy
and more of a setting one that can adapt
to myriad circumstances as the medium
fluctuates and evolves they set the
stage for what could be a tragic horror
story or a sandbox power fantasy in any
form of entertainment the most memorable
zombie stories act as a mirror they
place humanity in a post-apocalyptic
petri dish observing how we might react
to a widespread disaster they show the
lengths characters will go to in order
to survive and the way they interact
with fellow human beings once the law
has faded and chaos reigns state of
decay is one of my favorite entries in
the zombie pantheon specifically because
it allows me to find my own stories in
an apocalyptic wasteland zombie fiction
has always been away for authors
directors and developers to confront
humanity's anxieties through a distorted
lens as Max Brooks author of the
fantastic world wars II said in a 2009
interview zombie stories give people the
opportunity to witness the end of the
world they've been secretly wondering
about while at the same time allowing
themselves to sleep at night because the
catalyst of that end is fictional
this is why George Romero the creator of
what we know as modern zombies set dawn
of the dead in a shopping mall he didn't
just want to make a zombie sequel he
wanted to comment on the worship that
consumerism attracted none of this is to
mention the various ways you can view
his original zombie film Night of the
Living Dead some see it as a critique of
the Vietnam War while others consider it
a look at Cold War politics others still
take it as a criticism of 1960s American
culture in general to quote the man
himself in an interview with the website
horror movies zombies are my ticket to
ride it's how I get a deal I don't care
what they are
I don't care where they came from they
could be any disaster they could be an
earthquake a hurricane whatever in my
mind they don't represent anything to me
except a global change of some kind and
the stories are about how people respond
or fail to respond to this and that's
really all they've ever represented to
me running with this logic I don't think
the popularity of zombie games is any
coincidence as opposed to movies or
books in which humans behave through the
perspective of the Creator games allow
us to see how we might react when given
agency of course games are nowhere near
as
heroing as a real-world apocalypse might
be but the immersion still allows for
some semblance of that decision-making
process games make upwards of 100
billion dollars a year if any form of
entertainment is indicative of where our
collective anxieties lie its video games
so it's no surprise that zombies have
arisen died and reanimated so many times
throughout the medium short history and
I'm not at all surprised to see them
coming back again no matter your stance
on Trump for exit gun control or
politics in general I think we can all
feel the division that these topics
cause I keep seeing the word surreal
plastered across advertisements and
social media and I see jokes about the
world actually ending I see the word
nuclear at every turn suddenly this new
influx of zombie games makes sense
zombies provide an easy excuse for
catharsis they're the perfect enemies
ones you don't have to feel bad about
killing ones you don't have to think
twice about before shooting in the face
yes the best zombie titles transcend
these simple tropes but it's these
tropes that make money in the first
place like Romero said it is these
tropes that give developers their ticket
to ride they can make innovation
possible and as game Hardware keeps
getting better and game developers keep
getting savvy er we're only going to see
better takes on the digital zombie
apocalypse and from there better
innovations in this medium we all love
criticized zombie games all you want
call them trite redundant or rope but I
think we'll always need them they can be
dumb and fun and a reason to just turn
off and play a game for a while but time
and time again developers have used them
to also push video games forward taking
reanimated corpses and giving us a new
way to look at them we might stumble on
a mediocre effort once in a while but as
long as zombies allow for creators to
keep making those efforts and taking
these risks I'm all on board
[Music]
[Music]
you